hello my name is Olivia Stricker and I'm
the commercial development manager at
the DIA pharma group we are located in
West Chester Ohio and we are a u.s.
distributor for many European
manufactured biomarker assays like the
ones that I'm going to talk about today
with that I'd like to start my talk
about measuring what matters exploring
two biomarkers or proliferation and cell
death which are tk1 and keratin 18 so to
start off I thought just talking about
generally biomarkers for diseases would
be a good place to start
and essentially reliable biomarkers that
are relevant to disease are useful for
drug discovery and development clinical
trials clinical research but the bigger
hope is to be able to take the markers
used during those processes and
translate them into clinical uses as
well the utility's of an excellent
biomarker are shown here
you know to be specific and sensitive
relevant to disease quantitative rapid
robust for clinical trial purposes
non-invasive sample collection is ideal
and for drug discovery and kind of
screening purposes high-throughput it's
also really valuable
very few markers can check all the boxes
here so scientists essentially needs to
be constantly looking for new tools to
use in this process for all disease
types I'm going to introduce two assays
that gia Pharma represents in the US
market one is TK one Eliza by a company
called aerosol and one is an a pop-top
apoptosis Eliza
a save by vlv bio and in Sweden my goal
is to tell the story of each of these
biomarkers and present some data from
publications that demonstrate their
utilities as great research tools in
oncology to study new drugs for solid
tumors it's important to note that both
of these are her research is only in the
US
so keep that in mind as we go through
this talk so I wanted you know moving
more focused in from just biomarkers for
any kind of drug
good biomarkers are needed for all
different types of the cancer cancers
that we're studying by we I mean
scientists I'm out I'm off the bench but
um so having good oncology markers on
hand is important obviously and when you
closely look at cancer it's essentially
a fundamentally a disease of
dysregulation of growth so when you have
cells that won't stop growing or won't
die when they're supposed to thus it
makes perfect sense that researchers
look at markers of both growth and death
and monitoring those two processes
design tests for cancer drugs that tell
scientists a lot about the win where and
how cancer drugs are working during all
stages of development the first portion
of the talk I'm gonna focus on is cell
proliferation Sao Paulo for Asian is a
major deal in cancer because normal
tissues are not actively don't have a
lot of actively dividing cells while
cancer tissues do have active dividing
cells the special processes they're
associated with proliferation have long
been targets for cancer drugs and
interfering with these processes are
newer ways of targeting
these cells for for cell death so used
in combo the drugs cancer drugs can
basically max outside cells damaged
while simultaneously prevent repair to
the DNA many of these same drug targets
and pieces of the proliferation process
might also serve us really great
biomarkers for identifying growing cells
and there while there are plenty of
those available to researchers and
listed here are some of them
some of them are measuring DNA some of
them are protein measurements the
problem is is that not all of these are
easy samples to access or easy assays to
perform so some of the most popular
protein markers are measured by
immunohistochemistry analysis and while
it's useful and effective it also has a
lot of drug drawbacks in the fact that
it requires biopsy which is invasive
it's labor-intensive
there can be sampling issues which lead
to love reproducibility and there's a
certain level of subjectivity involved
so having a blood marker would be a with
much higher throughput and would
translate better to clinical research
testing so one of these markers it's
actually currently used for some IFC
analysis might be something that would
fit that need and that markers TK 1 so
TK 1 is a thymidine kinase it has
enzymatic activity and its key function
is in the synthesis of DNA it's made
during S phase and then is degraded
after the cells divide and in cancer
events it seems like k1 loses this kind
of cell cycle associated regulation and
is generally up regulated now there are
athletes for TK 1 their enzymatic in
nature and TK 1 is already quite
established as a biomarker for blood
cancer as a blood cancer biomarker but
the problem is is that many many of the
essays are radioactive in nature and
thus the activity si is not an ideal in
addition to that newer data suggests
that in the case of TK one activity
levels might not exactly be better than
the but the best measurement to make and
that is demonstrated by the data shown
here where in the case of solid tumors
CMT k1 protein levels have also
shown to be elevated with several tumor
types the example shown here is a
prostate cancer type where when the tk1
activity is high the expression of the
protein is low and when the activity is
low you actually see higher level of
protein in the serum thus you know a
critical piece of the information in the
amount or level of tk1 protein is being
missed in the activity si so this drives
a need for an antigen based si the
current tk1 detection and assay is out
there again there you know activities so
interesting and very relevant disease
disease it's a blood cancer biomarker
but the assays are not always easily
accessible in the fact that they're
radioactive in some cases in other cases
they're on closed systems or they can be
expensive and this also doesn't feel
kind of the gap in the need for
detection of antigen for solid tumor
purposes previous attempts at making a
more standard iliza kit have produced
data that show that the readout of the
lesyk it doesn't exactly correlate well
with the activity assay that's already
been established the issue with standard
Eliza is that tk1
outside of the cell often forms the
large complexes and these complexes
might be masking the epitopes that are
recognized in the antibodies of the
Eliza assay so that being said a Swedish
company called eros ohm has spent some
time developing analyzed a kit that
addresses the complex problems and
really fills this gap in a need for an
antigen assay aerosol developed a
analyzed kit called TK 210 Eliza and
they have addressed the complex issues
by developing a buffer that dissociate
the complexes and increases detection
capacity so when these epitopes aren't
masked you get a more robust assay and
they also have developed a replaced
polyclonal antibodies with a monoclonal
antibody and amino acid 210 of the TK 1
protein that increases the sensitivity
so the combination of this results in a
more robust Eliza that as you can see
here demonstrates a strong correlation
with the gold standard of the enzymatic
activity so protein correlates with
activity and then also the way that they
have addressed it increases sensitivity
and specificity so that this kit can be
used as a research tool for solid tumors
so shown here is blood donors versus
serum samples blood donors versus
subjects with solid tumors and you can
see that there is a robustness that
might lend itself to being a great tool
for doing research on solid tumors the
benefits of the 2 K or the GK - 10 as a
kid kind of all circle around -
advantages that make this kit better
suited for cell culture and preclinical
work over the activity those two
benefits or advantages are the fact that
the antigenic detection of TK 1 is
specific and allows for distinguishing
between TK 1 and TK 2 which TK 2 is
actually found in the mitochondria but
also has been by meeting kinase activity
so an activity si would not be able to
distinguish between the two whereas this
energetic
si does allow for that that's useful for
clinical like so not clinical but cell
culture and other studies on cell based
levels and then for a preclinical assays
TK 1 can actually just the TK 2 10 Eliza
can distinguish between humans he can
and mouse tk1 and that's you know a
critical tool when people are looking at
xenograph acute human xenograft models
in allowing for any tk1
in the blood samples of those animals to
be attributed to the actual tumor that's
human derived versus the mouse and you
know um the the major advantage with
these xenograph models is that you'd be
able to measure tk1 in the blood over
time and you don't need to sacrifice
animals at each time point since it's in
the in the blood that translates to
clinical research benefits and the fact
that they're non-invasive serum based
markers and this would be advantageous
to kind of two different groups of
people doing clinical research so these
two groups are kind of who aerosol wants
to get the word out about the 210 eliza
kit that's the hematology groups to kind
of already know tk1 as a biomarker and
for them the eliza kit would be more of
an old dog with a new trick in the fact
that they're you studying activity but
it might be the case that protein levels
are just as good as activity
measurements without the hassle of the
activity assets the other group is solid
tumor groups that are doing research on
solid tumors like breast cancer or
prostate cancer this tk1 in general is a
new kid on the block
so the 210 the TK 210 eliza kit is a new
marker to look at for the research
that's already being explored so that's
where the value of this kit lies and um
here are and this is an example of some
convincing solid tumor data that can be
seen when comparing activity as a marker
to protein as a marker so on the top
here we show activity measured in breast
cancer subjects research subjects and
the bottom here is protein being
measured
breast-cancer research subjects and the
protein levels are much better at
detecting subjects with breast cancer
and also distinguishing kinds of
severity of disease states within those
cancer subjects and in the same
publication authors also explore a
relationship of tk1 protein with breast
cancer or with prostate cancer and they
note the same trend can be seen so
keeping in the breast cancer research
world tk1 protein is also a better
indicator for subjects with breast
cancer than commonly used markers at the
present so in fact when the markers are
used in combination the data shows an
improvement in the sensitivity and
specificity so that would be the black
dotted line as compared to the gold
standard currently is such as the blue
dotted line shown here
so although the kit is newer to the
commercial market it should be included
in all kinds of studies investigating
new cancer drugs especially for
preclinical xenograph models and drug
classes that might directly have
downstream implications for tk1
things like cdk4 six inhibitors might be
really interested in tk1 as a biomarker
here is that extra data for the prostate
cancer that kind of mirror also reflect
the the breast cancer research as a
marker showing the protein is a better
indicator in this case than activity for
these subjects with prostate cancer so
many more studies are ongoing and
publications are much anticipated using
this air assault kit err so as the
company is due to present more data at
AACR in the spring of 2020 so if you're
interested in TK wanna know how to stay
tuned for that on to cell death as
opposed to proliferation and cell death
would be the flip side of the
growth markers and also to be noted the
desired outcome for cancer cells all
cancer cells know
so in general to cell death modalities
are kind of more standard or traditional
these two different mechanisms are
necrosis and apoptosis and as I'm sure
many people know necrosis is can be
thought of more of a homicide cell death
due to like infections or toxin or
trauma you'd see swelling and loss of
membrane integrity and this kind of
results in a lot of inflammation of the
surrounding tissue whereas on the
opposite side of that apoptosis can be
thought of more of a suicide cell death
and is very programmed with membrane
blebbing and a pop tonic bodies that are
then gobbled up by phagocytic cells
around them and results in less much
less inflammation so this is really
important when you think about oncology
and while the the verdict is still out
on whether necrosis or apoptosis is a
more desired result for effective cancer
therapies it seems like the evidence is
leaning much towards to the a buck Tata
cath lab as being preferred and that's
because there's a lot less inflammation
in the surrounding tissue and that
inflammation possibly feeds cancer
selves so for that reason you know
oncologists are interested in apoptosis
apoptosis has two different kind of
starting points one is intrinsically and
one is extrinsically the entrance at
part of the pathway is activated by a
lot of that DNA damaging drugs and
checkpoint inhibitors whereas new
classes of drugs are being developed for
the extrinsic pathway that actually
activate the death receptors and that
whole signaling cascade so apoptosis is
a target of a lot of cancer drugs but
it's also
mechanism in which cells become
resistant to cancer drugs and the fact
that you know they will often bypass a
lot of these pathetic pathways when they
become resistant to cancer drugs so for
all of those reasons and all of those
drugs and development biomarkers that
specifically measure apoptosis and
necrosis have a tremendous amount of
value to researchers focus they're a pop
tonic butter biomarkers that many
researchers are using are common and
they're useful they're listed some of
them are circled in red here like
cytochrome C and nucleated DNA changes
in the membrane activated caspases and
cytokeratins the desired qualities would
be much like any good biomarker and the
fact that they're apoptosis specific
quantitative they're high throughput for
drug screening if they're an endpoint
marker that you don't have to capture a
cell in the middle of apoptosis in order
to get this readout and that they can be
found in the blood so unfortunately many
of the desired qualities aren't
delivered by every single biomarker you
know they might not be specific to
apoptosis or the product of apoptosis
might not be stable for effective
quantitation so I thought I would
explore the cytokeratin as a biomarker
more in depth the set of care to our
favorite site keratin here at DIA pharma
is carrots an 18 so it's obviously one
of many different keratin types and just
like any good protein it has many names
depending on the area of research that
you're in it can go buy carrots an 18 it
can go buy cytokeratin 18 K 18 or CK 18
it is found in mainly epithelial cells
of the body and their tissues so liver
lung intestines breast prostate are some
main ones
it is not expressed
in the brain neurons muscle connective
tissue and importantly in the in cells
or cells of the blood and that's
attractive for the reason that any
massive cell death and the immune system
actually won't interfere with
measurements of keratin 18 so that's an
advantage especially in oncology and
also there's a laundry list of
publications that kind of associated
increases in serum levels of keratin 18
with the presence of tumors and things
like the liver the lung the intestines
of breast or prostate cancer so there's
a lot of interest to oncology land if
you look at cell death in the context of
keratin 18 in necrotic conditions you
know total intact keratin 18 can spill
out into the surrounding cell whereas
under a pup chata conditions you get
activated caspases that will cleave
keratin 18 at very specific amino acid
sequences so the result in turn evoked
otic so is that you get lots of small
pieces or fragments of carrots 19 either
packaged into these phagocytic bodies or
spilling out into the extracellular
space around themselves diving in to
look really specifically at keratin 18
as i said when a bap ptosis occurs it
actually gets cleaved at two specific
locations and kerosene 18 has proved to
be a significant interest primarily
because of several monoclonal antibodies
that have been developed against the
protein so they've been developed and
then they've been characterized by the
lunar lab at Karolinska Institute and
then commercially developed further into
Eliza kits by a company called Aviva
which is then purchased by another
Swedish company and is now known as VLB
bio these antibodies are called m5 m6 nm
30 and the m5 and m6 recognize the the
body of the perks
keratin 18 protein whereas the m30 is a
very special party or very special
antibody in the fact that it
specifically recognizes the café's
cleaved keratin 18 so it only sees the
neo epitope that was created after that
cleavage occurs and it also goes by a
barrage of names some of them are names
of the neo epitope then some of them are
caspase cleaved cytokeratin 18 and
caspase cleaved keratin 18 so you'll see
the a popped attic refer product
referred to as all of those names it's
also important to note that the m30
antibody name has been trademarked in in
addition to the Eliza kits that have
been developed they're also trademarked
names so m65 and the m30 Eliza m65 is
comprised of the m6 and m5 monoclonal
antibodies they detect both the
full-length intact keratin 18 as well as
the apoptosis product whereas that m30
antibody only recognizes that neo
epitope so the Eliza kit that contains
them dirty animal only recognizes a
pathetic products it's used together
these two products are very powerful in
the fact that the ratios of the two can
tell us about cell death mechanism which
in the land of drug development is
actually very important whether things
are necrotic or apoptotic so when you
have high apoptosis product measured by
m30
with high total keratin 18 measured by m
65 that indicates an a pep tonic event
so here I show data with a breast cancer
cell line treated with a drug that
induces apoptosis code cisplatin so when
you add cisplatin you see that you get
an increase in both the apoptosis and
the total keratin 18 product and that
the product note is actually stable over
time you see an increase that from 24
hours to 48 hours
if you treat those cells with an
apoptosis inhibitor the Z fad indicated
here you can actually block the
apoptosis product from accumulating but
not the total character Nate team from
accumulating so that would be an example
of what an apotheosis event looks like
on the other side a necrosis event the
same cell line treated with a necrosis
inducing drug called a Lego myosin
induces total kerosene 18 in the media
but does not produce high levels of the
apoptosis product in the media so while
that is a characteristic that is very
probably powerful for a lot of cell
culture and screening work other
characteristics of the m30 antibody is
that they're specific it is specific for
keratin 18 and apoptosis so shown here
in this figure I have no I have with the
author I didn't do any of the Stork the
author shows that ck 18 is only detected
when it's transfected into these ck 18 -
cells and that the neo epitope is
actually only detected when those cells
are also treated with an apoptosis
inducing drug for cross reactivity
studies data shows that mouse rat or dog
peptides don't compete off the human
peptide when binding to m 30 so
therefore you could we can say that M 30
does not detect Mouse or breath
apoptosis keratin 18 product that is
extra important for any xenograph models
that are done so just like the aerosol
kit the m30 apoptosis only recognizes
the human caspase cleave keratin 18 in
the serum of these animals and there are
papers demonstrating that you can use
mouse or rat models
a variety of tumor models and a variety
of drugs types to study the
pharmacokinetics and the thermodynamics
of how drugs act on different tumor
types so this is example of data that
helps demonstrate that we're in this
first part of the figure they're using a
mouse model with a head and neck tumor
and you can see that over time you
actually get a very dramatic increase
between untreated and treated tumors and
the amount of apoptotic product that
happens so if you look at 0 96 hours
there's a lot higher levels of apoptosis
going on and then if you take that same
model you can do a dose response curve
as well and get really nice tight dosing
information the same author replicated
those that work in a rat model of colon
cancer and show that you know you can
the assay is reproducible in a plasma
assay so that's really powerful use and
xenograph models lastly i'm showing you
data that's see on the left a prostate
tumor is not responding to a cancer drug
indicated by the increase in the PSA
levels and the Sica 18 a peptide product
remains flatlined on the right when the
cancer drug is effective the tumor
shrinks and the PSA level plummets and
it's observed that the CK 18 actually
Peaks with each cycle given to the
subject between day 5 and day 7 so this
data suggests that serum CK 18
measurements may be useful for assessing
the treatment effects and the montt the
method you know it's kind of ideal for
clinical trials and the fact that the
product is stable in the in the serum
and can be stored for a long period of
time and is ideal for kind of
multicenter clinical research trials
the measurement of the cast is cleaved
keratin 18 and serum might be useful for
comparisons of efficiencies between
different drug modalities and that's
pretty key issue during development of
novel anti-cancer drugs some there's a
lot more data out there to look up I
just don't have time to go through all
that today but I appreciate everyone for
bearing with me and you know allowing me
to give you the take-home messages that
there's two biomarkers that should be
included when looking at especially
xenograph models one is tk1 at the
protein level there's a new kit by
aerosol it's called GK - ten Eliza
and it is more sensitive in robust than
any kid that's been available in the
past and better than at the activity
measurement for solid tumor research and
the other marker is that of keratin
eighteen specifically the a pop tonic
product that's measured by the m30
apoptosis Eliza kit it can be used in
tandem with the m65 Eliza kit to kind of
give a lot of extra information on the
mechanism of cell death and can provide
kinetics in humans even and graph models
to do solid tumor studies as well so
both of these can be used to the whole
drug development process and with that I
just wanted to remind everybody that I
am that dia Pharma is the company that
offers these products in the US we are
the exclusive distributor for vlv bio
you know we kind of specialize in a lot
of really technical clinical or not
clinical technical support and can
provide a lot of input or extra data or
answer any questions about these
specific products we have these as well
as many other oncology markers that are
kind of more unique in nature
and they can all be found at our website
which is dia Pharma comm or you can feel
free to reach out to any of our team
members at the contact that I have
listed here also we will be at AACR in
the spring of 2020 and you can always
find out what our latest and greatest is
on our website or on Arlington so with
that I'm finished thank you